- Hey team, welcome to
our session here today.
I'm really excited to be your host.
My name is Soulat Khan.
I've been with Amazon for
about six and a half years.
I'm with a group of esteemed colleagues
from some of our select customers.
They're gonna introduce themselves.
And the reason why we have this session is
to have our audiences
learn from the experiences
from our customers and their
transformational journey
with their SAP workloads on AWS.
So, as a quick introduction,
I'm gonna have our esteemed
panel introduce themselves,
and we'll start with Pete,
we'll go to Purna, and then Simon.
Pete, over to you.
- Thanks, Soulat. So, my
name is Pete Rauchenstein.
I am a cloud engineer slash
SAP basis platform guy
at Mondelez International.
If you're not familiar with Mondelez,
we are one of the largest
consumer products companies,
making wonderful, delicious
treats like Oreos, Cadbury,
and many other fun goodies.
Really excited to be here.
- Thanks, Pete. I love all
those goodies too, by the way.
- Hi, I am Purnachand Aravapalli.
I work with Colgate-Palmolive
as a director for infrastructure
and database architecture.
And you know, the
Colgate-Palmolive is the one
of the global consumer company
with $20 billion turnover.
- Thanks, Purna. Simon, over to you.
- My name is Simon Davies.
I am the general manager for
what's known as core banking
at the Commonwealth Bank of Australia.
For those of you who aren't
familiar, Commonwealth Bank,
or CBA, is the largest bank in Australia.
We bank about one in
three people in Australia,
so just to give you an indication.
- That's amazing, so for the
first part of this section,
I'm gonna ask our colleagues
here what caused them
to choose AWS for their SAP
transformational journey.
A couple of questions,
and just a couple of housekeeping items.
We're not gonna have any Q and
A at the end of this session,
but if you have any
questions, we invite you
to please join us at Smith
and Wollensky tomorrow.
And if you have any
questions on where to go
and where to sign up,
I've got two of our marketing
gentlemen right in the front.
You can come ask them to
make sure you register
and you can access both our customers
and folks that are from SAP and AWS.
All right, so for our
first question, Simon,
you just introduced yourself
from the Commonwealth Bank of Australia.
This is a company that processes
40% of Australia's transactions.
This is a transaction workload
that is really risk averse.
Can you talk to us about
what made you select AWS
in your transformational journey, please?
- Yeah, so as you said, 40% of
transactions in the economy,
so it's, CBA is Australia's biggest bank,
almost one in two times money
changes hands in the economy,
it goes through our SAP system.
So you buy lunch, buying your groceries,
sending money to people,
good chance it goes through this system.
So not only is this CBA's
most critical system,
but in a real sense this
underpins the entire economy.
So it was a big decision for us to make.
Just by way of a like frame of reference,
core banking transformations
in general, SAP or no,
about 70% of them fail.
And you often end up
seeing CIOs or CEOs move on
as a result, so quite a big obligation.
We chose AWS, I think, for
probably three reasons.
And the first is really
about scale and resilience.
I think AWS were a good
cultural fit for us.
They shared our value
of customer obsession,
and they deeply understood
that the level of obligation
that a workload of this magnitude had.
And they had the experience
in running other very,
very large SAP workloads
to give us that trust
that this would be a
safe place for us to run.
I think the second reason is really
in the engineering partnership.
Running a workload of this scale,
it's a little bit different
to your traditional ERP
in that this is like very,
a very high throughput online
transaction processing,
really tight NFRs, low
latency online workload.
We knew that we would
need to engineer our way
out of a lot of problems.
And certainly we discovered
quite a few things
that aren't in the
standard SAP architectures
that we needed to work through.
And we did things with AWS to
solve some of those problems.
There was a new feature
introduced into EC2 as a result,
which I'm really proud of,
that all SAP customers
can leverage from here.
And that partnership,
having AWS with us every step of the way
to tackle those really hard problems,
was really, really important.
And then I think the last one is
when we thought about this migration,
it wasn't really just a case
of lift and shifting the technology.
Certainly we had the
same 2027 end of service
that I think a lot of us were
staring down the barrel of
that was the original impetus.
But it was also like an opportunity for us
to be really honest about ourself,
about the state of our technology stack,
which had, we'd lived with
for about a decade and a half,
and we came from sort of mainframe
and mid-range rock solid.
But characteristically,
rocks are not known
for their flexibility or agility.
And that was certainly true of
our operations, quite siloed.
We had eight different teams
that ran the stack, top to bottom.
They all spoke different
and obscure languages.
It was really difficult to
like coordinate between them
or get anything done.
Moving to S/4 on AWS
gave us the opportunity
to look at this from a
full stack perspective.
But not just with that
workload in isolation either,
but we could land it in an ecosystem
that was constantly evolving
and innovating itself
and allow us to take advantage of the best
that AWS have to offer, and
more seamlessly integrate
with the rest of our workloads,
be it our digital channels
or some of the work
that we're doing in the
agentic and AI space.
So yeah, definitely AWS, we
thought, was a good partner,
not just to run this safely,
but to run it in bold new ways.
- That's excellent, Simon.
Those are some really nice gems.
Thank you for selecting AWS.
So the audience, just to summarize,
if you are going through
your selection process,
looking for a partner, a
cultural fit is really important.
I heard Simon say that, it's really good.
Not only is it leadership principles,
but having an innovation partner
where you can work backwards
from your customer needs,
like co-development of EC2
health monitor health checks,
which is really important as well.
And then for scale,
so experience in scale
is really important.
I would tell you if the
audience here in the room
is thinking about going to
move their SAP workloads
or move into S/4HANA,
or even consider RISE,
that's a workload that you
really want to be active
and functioning at all times.
And you heard from Simon
on the choice that CBA made
for selecting to run their
SAP workloads on AWS.
That's great, Simon. Pete, over to you.
You've got some experience
running SAP in the cloud already.
Can you talk a little bit about
your journey and what came
to selecting AWS?
- Sure.
I think it's really
important to understand
that everyone's got a little bit
of a different starting
point to their journey.
Mondelez is, if people
haven't heard of that name,
it's 'cause it's only been
around about 16 years.
It's really a combination
of the Kraft North America business
and the Cadbury business in Europe
and other parts of the world.
And as a result, a lot
of our core systems are,
they have different approaches
that have grown over time.
And part of our journey,
and I think the challenge
is how do you go from,
I have some systems that are
on a legacy on-prem data center,
and then I have other systems
where we did a number of
migrations to the cloud earlier
on a different hyperscaler.
Started that journey, I think, in 2017,
a little bit before my time.
But I think it was clear
that running things differently
wasn't really going to scale
as we wanted to continue our journey.
Now that, I kind of pause and let's talk
about just why AWS first.
- Love to hear that
- Because I think there's kind of
two different conversations.
- Yep.
- About four years ago,
some of my colleagues and I,
who are all here in the audience,
joined Mondelez to really stand up
an internal cloud
engineering organization.
And a lot of what Simon
was just talking about
really resonates, about having
a consistent operating model.
One of the things that
we're really proud of is
that everything that we have done in AWS,
with the exception of the vending
of the very first root account,
has all been done using
infrastructure as code
and the Account Factory for Terraform.
We've had a wonderful
partnership from day one
with AWS Pro Service.
We've set up kind of this
really awesome plumbing
where we can go from
requirement to realization,
in many cases, in less than a few hours.
It's a really funny story.
My boss actually deployed some servers
from his son's soccer
game, from his phone,
with some of the tooling that we've built.
So that's really interesting.
But a lot of that focus
was on the non-SAP stacks.
We have started recently
our journey to S/4HANA.
Again, if this were just a
straight upgrade process,
it would probably be a much
less difficult journey.
But because we're sort of
addressing some of the,
what I'll call foundational
issues of the past,
of having different systems
that were built by different teams
over different times in
different hyperscalers
with different OSs and different versions,
there's a lot of just
foundational harmonization work
that is happening at the same time
that we are also going to S/4 on RISE,
so new ways of working for
the entire organization.
You've got a very experienced
basis and platform team
that works with us.
And I think it's somewhere
in the neighborhood
of like 425 years of combined experience,
so we're very, very-
- Awesome.
- We're very, very particular
about how things are done.
And so shifting to RISE,
running those workloads
in a new hyperscaler
with a new way of working, that
added a little bit of risk.
So for us, it was really important
to build on the wonderful relationship
that we started developing
with AWS in 2021
to be able to say, "Well,
how can we de-risk this?
How can we make this easier
for the organization?"
Having a trusted partner
like AWS to help us navigate,
hey, have we set everything up correctly
from an infrastructure perspective?
Does our landing zone look correct?
Hey, we have to have capacity
reservation conversations.
Some of our colleagues here have helped us
in many, many ways, helping
SAP even beat their own SLAs
for delivering some of
that infrastructure.
- Awesome, excellent.
- So building on
that trusted partnership
and having people that know
us has been really awesome.
- That's great, Pete, thank you so much.
That's really awesome.
I mean, I love the
comment you made earlier
and resonates with me is
that everyone has a
different starting line,
but it's the journey that really matters.
And speaking of the journey,
I'd love to have Purna share your journey.
I think I caught up with
you a little bit earlier
and I learned that you kind
of made the decision of AWS
coming to re:Invent just last year.
So I'd love to learn a little
bit more about that, Purna.
- Yeah, so again, the good point mentioned
by Simon and Peter, we
have different perspectives
and different journeys started.
So from the Colgate, it's
a 250-year-old company,
serving across world, 200
countries and territories.
So our mission is like
re-imagining the healthier future
for all the people,
their pets, and planet.
It's a strong statement from Colgate,
so we have been, it's always
been the transformation.
You can imagine companies
surviving for 250 years
has been going through
the great transformation.
So we started our journey.
So currently we have six
production landscapes running
on RISE on the AWS platform.
We are going to migrate another
eight systems by mid 2027,
including our most critical
transactional systems.
So we are going good.
So we have the, we are on the
plans, everything going good.
So then the point, your point,
how did we start that, right?
So we have been there, we
have been in the cloud.
So the first thing, so we went with the,
when we started the things,
we were brainstorming
internally and we decided,
so okay, these are the
things we want to go with.
So the first thing is that
the performance, right?
Where do we get the performance?
Always what we say is the same or better.
So we have the, again,
like Simon mentioned,
that we are rock solid on-prem.
So we are running, we are
with the systems like IBM.
But transformation is important.
So then we decided, okay,
let's go with the performance.
And the second one is with
the roadmap aligned with SAPs.
And the performance,
when we were looking at
what we are done, we had
done the benchmarking
across the comparable workloads.
So we have seen AWS has
met that expectations.
So we have seen the desirable performance,
so that gave us confidence
to go in the scale.
So when we wanted to run large systems,
that gave us confidence.
And also the roadmap that
SAP has aligned with AWS
is also gave us confidence.
And the other thing is that we
want to diversify the cloud.
Diversification is important.
That is our company strategy,
so that is one of the things.
So all together came up, really
gave us the path to do this.
And again, just to add that
we migrated our systems
to S/4 in 2019.
So we always work very
closely with our partners.
We don't call as vendors,
we call it as partners.
So when we started SAP, so we did in 2019,
so for our business case
was only to go to cloud.
So we are, we had our
business case covered
in the transformation.
- I'm jealous.
- Yeah, it was not easy
because you always, you can
show the benefits with the,
what do you call S/4 transformation
and cloud together, right?
For us, the challenge is that,
oh, you have transformation
already for five years,
how do you do that?
So that's where those three principles,
and also the same or
better, clearly helped us.
We are running six systems
so far, we are doing that.
- That's awesome, Purna.
Thanks for sharing that.
I'm jealous too, that's pretty amazing
that you guys started in the cloud
and moving into transformation.
That was really good.
So like Amazon has a
lot of programs to offer
to SAP customers and really
to all enterprise customers,
whether it's in the areas of assessments,
or building business cases,
or helping you accelerate
your migration journey
with our partners or directly
with our services teams.
And the next couple of set
of questions are really
to kind of get a lessons learned.
Like did you use some of the programs?
Did you get some good experiences?
What could you share with our audience
from your transformation journey?
I'll start off with Pete.
Pete, love to learn about
what kind of programs worked
for you and any lessons learned you'd like
to share with the crowd.
- Sure, I mean, I think the biggest one
that has been very successful for us
has been our relationship with
AWS Professional Services.
They have been with us from day one,
and really working with
our core engineering team,
pushing the boundaries of what's possible
and how do I do this.
I think we even have weekly
office hours still to this day,
four years in, where we're learning
about the latest techniques.
We have a chance to ask questions,
to work on things together.
One of our colleagues who has been with us
pretty much from the first, from day one,
is still here with us today,
here at AWS re:Invent.
So having that kind of
deep personal relationship
has been really, really wonderful.
I would also say like for us,
maybe not an AWS-specific
specific program,
but using forums like this
to meet other leaders in the space.
We have a relationship with an SI partner.
Am I allowed to say names?
- Yes, you can.
- Lemongrass, who we
met here at re:Invent,
four years ago, I believe.
And again, the question was who's the best
at taking SAP to the cloud.
We know that's gonna
be a thing for us soon,
so building that relationship
and finding people that think
about systems engineering
and automation the same way that we do.
Everything that we want to
be able to do is about scale,
doing things in a repeatable way,
leveraging IAC principles where we can,
automating the mundane
so that we can focus
on those really truly transformational
value-added activities.
Getting a chance to
meet partners like that
here at re:Invent has been wonderful.
And of course having
access to a broad array
of subject matter experts,
people who can maybe take a
look under the hood at some
of the things that we've done
in RISE, offer suggestions,
find things that may or
may not be issues later,
but it's always good to walk
into things eyes wide open.
- That's excellent. Thanks
for sharing that, Pete.
Simon, I'll ask you a question.
Can you touch on some of the
quantitative improvements
and organizational change you've seen
by moving your transformation
journey forward?
Love to learn from you and your team.
- Yeah, absolutely.
I'd probably look at this
through three lenses, right?
The first one, I think, is
performance improvements.
This was certainly a
system of record for us,
our most critical system of record.
But increasingly, we wanted to turn it
into like a system of intelligence.
We wanted to do more things
with deep personalization,
behavioral banking, and
that requires grunt, right?
So what we actually saw
moving away from our legacy,
like DB2 on mainframe
R/3 stack to S/4 on AWS,
we got about a 30% improvement,
and that was for both online,
like web service traffic,
but also web services would obviously
improve their response time,
and it kinda manifests most readily
in things like balance updates happen
a lot faster than they used to.
Previously, someone would make a payment
and then they'd have to
kind of refresh the screen
to see their balance update.
Now that happens straight away.
It also enables sort of
more inline processing,
things like fraud checks, et cetera,
that can happen in real time.
But also like for the batch workload,
that also happens much more quickly.
And it allows us to do things
like increasingly do
customer-based pricing,
which requires millions and millions
of recalculations every day
to determine what is the best price
for a given customer segment.
And we got a quite a bit
more headroom with this move
that allows us to do more
in those batch windows, which is great.
Resilience, I think, is the second lens.
And we sort of touched
on that a little bit
in terms of the operating model,
but I think one of the other things
that I'm really proud
of with this move was,
our recovery time objective previously,
if we were to do a site swap,
RTO was about an hour and a half.
We used to like rehearse this every year,
and it'd be a bit of a
manufactured exercise.
Everyone would get at their
keyboards, get warmed up,
they've got their coffee,
they've got their run sheet,
start your engines.
And in that manner, we could kind
of like choreograph the entire thing
and execute it in about 30 minutes.
It's pretty good, but
it's a bit artificial.
When we moved to S/4, like out of the box,
we were seeing about a 16-minute
failover when we did HANA,
15, 16 minutes, still pretty good,
but like I said, very,
very downtime sensitive,
a sensitive environment in banking,
we wanted to optimize
that a little bit more.
So we did some deep engineering with SAP,
with Red Hat, and with AWS,
and we actually pushed in a
whole bunch of improvements
at the both, at the Red Hat kernel level
to Pacemaker, to that config,
and as I said, an enhancement to EC2
with the skip shutdown
feature that was released.
So it's awesome to see some of the work
that we've done-
- That's excellent.
- To try to push the boundaries
make its way back into the main code line
for these software vendors and for AWS,
and we can see that
all customers in future
will be able to benefit from
some of this innovation.
- That's great.
- Which is awesome.
And I think the last,
the last thing I'd probably
call out here is efficiency.
I mean, firstly,
infrastructure efficiency.
We came from very, very
expensive specialized compute.
That's not gonna be true for everyone.
But the move to Commodity
X86 saw a 30% reduction
in just infrastructure
costs, which is wild.
But more than that, I like Pete's journey,
'cause we had a very similar approach,
it was automate everything top to bottom.
And that's not just provisioning,
but our operations as well.
So it's things like scale
out, restart, fail over,
start, stop, cluster moves,
all of this kind of stuff.
And what that did was it took out hundreds
of manual touch points
per month.
- That's excellent.
- And it moved us to just executing
these automated pipelines.
Our focus is now less
about keeping the lights on
and we get to focus more
now on building what's next.
And one of the things we
talked about this morning
was got a real focus now on AI ops.
How do we build a system
that detects anomalies
and learns and takes action?
So that's what I'm really excited about.
- That's really excellent.
Yeah, I've heard you mention
resiliency a couple of times,
and I love the perspective
that it's not only being
resilient within your environment,
but also in your operations
and your daily activities
that can be automated as well.
I love hearing that.
And Purna, you mentioned
you've got a number
of environments running in the cloud.
Can you kind of touch on which
programs worked well for you,
and kind of lessons learned
in moving that journey into AWS as well?
- Yeah, sure, so we
started this AWS journey,
mainly specific SAP RISE, early,
first quarter of this year.
So you can imagine like it is six months,
within almost eight months,
we migrated six production landscapes.
- That's pretty big.
- And again, we have a strong cloud team,
so they understand the cloud very well,
the cloud technologies,
but we are kind of something new to AWS.
So for us, the enablement was key because,
and we had very limited time
to get into that, right?
So considering that critically
of SAP applications,
so the focus was to get that support,
ensure that we have everything needed
for the RISE migrations.
So it's like crawl, walk, and run.
So we started on those things.
So we used the immersion days
and AWS Well-Architected Framework
and help from account team.
So initially the main key was
with the connectivity, right?
So for the users to connect
with our existing infrastructure to AWS,
it was key for the
performance and everything.
So we worked closely with AWS,
we had a workshop very
quickly, like on-prem workshop.
They flew, they had like
multiple discussions
and we were discussing about
the connectivity patterns,
so the size of different options.
So finally we could deploy
the interconnect very fast
and we could run it very well.
So it helped us in the
performance area as well.
And in addition to that,
the support from the AWS
account team was very good.
So they have been helping us throughout.
So we have like, even
we go through SAP RISE,
we do have regular
calls with the AWS team,
and they do discuss the requirements,
they understand what
is coming new with us.
And they had a couple of sessions too,
mainly on the security side.
So we are working on,
we are trying to build
our AWS security posture.
We are going to, that is
something really helped us.
- That's really good.
So immersion days,
well-architected reviews
are all service offerings
that anybody in our audience
can choose to leverage.
These are offered at no cost
and they're complimentary.
My team leads them, your
account teams can lead them,
and we can bring in our
innovation roadmap to go through
where it makes sense to
deliver your business outcomes.
- Yeah, and just to add one more point,
we were doing the proof of concept,
like before deciding RISE.
So the team was, when we were working,
were so much comfortable.
They could talk in the customer language.
- Loving that.
- So sometimes it's hard
to get like why to,
because every enterprise
has their own requirement.
So we see that the AWS team
could understand the
requirements and help us,
like what is needed,
and ensure that even the
testing was successful.
- That's excellent.
Yeah, working backwards from
customer requirements is key.
In fact, one of the biggest
announcements we made this year
was our AI co-innovation program with SAP,
where we work with our
customers and partners
to build out their agentic capability,
leveraging SAPs full
stack, and AWS full stack.
And on topic of
modernization and innovation,
I'd love to hear from our
panel your perspective
of what it means to modernize.
Simon, if I might, starting off with you,
core banking innovation is pretty big,
and pretty huge and close to your heart.
We'd love to learn about what is,
what's happening next in
the modernization journey
for core banking, with respect to CBA,
and really the economy in Australia.
- Yeah, I mean, I think, like
you said, it's a journey.
And even getting here, we
definitely learned a lot.
AI certainly being a thing
we experimented deeply with,
with how we use this for building
more robust automated test cases,
as well as increasing
engineering productivity
for a lot of the code remediation
that we needed to do with the move.
And I think the state of the art
for the tools changes so rapidly.
We started off with Amazon Q
and we had kind of mixed success.
We also experimented a little bit
with tools like Roo and
Cline, or GitHub Copilot.
We've got some sort of clunky
workflows at the moment.
A lot of these plugins
don't exist for Eclipse,
so we end up with this situation
where developers are using VS code,
and then copying and pasting
from VS code into Eclipse to push changes.
So you can imagine, from a
developer experience perspective,
you get a little bit of pushback,
but the people who are
really, really keen,
they get really excited and
they can live with that.
But that can only get better.
But then we, you think about
beyond the actual implementation
and change on the system itself.
What this system is,
is not just like our
biggest system of record,
it's about 90% of all of our customer
and account and transactional data in CBA.
You really need to think about it
as the richest source of
customer behavioral insights
that we have in the bank.
We often hear it said that
data is the fuel for AI.
There is no higher octane
fuel than what we have here,
so really being able to
exploit that is important.
Historically, there was
sort of high friction
with getting access to that data
and that was a combination of,
in kind of a lockdown ecosystem,
but also some like performance constraints
on being able to push data out en masse.
With the move that we've made here,
we can actually event
everything that comes out
of this system in real time,
makes a real live signals
coming out of this system,
tested up to about 5,000
transactions per second.
- That's amazing.
- So it means that we can
get that customer data
to our data scientists,
to other engineering teams
who are building new agentic solutions
a lot faster than we
were ever able to before.
So straight out of HANA to Amazon MSK,
we can push it through
like Kinesis to SageMaker,
and increasingly we're doing things
with Bedrock and AgentCore
as we sort of imagine
what the next decade of
agentic banking might mean,
and experimenting with
Bedrock and AgentCore
and what capabilities that
will give us to deliver
more hyper-personalized
behavioral banking experiences,
like intelligent experiences
to our customers.
So we think the potential is huge,
and this one move that we've
made to something so critical,
certainly, to CBA has
just been foundational.
I think it's gonna unlock,
like I said, the next decade for us.
- That's excellent, I can feel the passion
and it's a really exciting space.
I would say to the audience, and Simon,
I'm gonna follow up with you as well.
We recently announced full
support for ABAP in Amazon Q Dev,
including the Eclipse plugin,
and we have a lot more planned.
So if anyone's interested,
we actually have a developer workshop.
I think we call it a,
I think it's called Developer
Workshop on a Chalk Talk,
where you can actually go
hands on keys with Amazon Q Dev
and start building out some
of those workflows yourself.
So I highly encourage our
audience to try that out.
And I love hearing the
modernization capability
that you have available.
We also have a lot planned around Strands
and AgentCore within Bedrock
to help you manage those agents as well.
So everybody who's listening in,
please keep a close eye on that space.
We'll have a few
announcements coming out soon.
Purna, I'd love to hear your
perspective on modernization,
what services you're leveraging
at Colgate-Palmolive too.
- Yeah, so for us, AWS is like
for SAP RISE core platform,
because SAP systems generally are the key,
the central thing where you get the data
and the data goes into the systems, right?
So what we are doing
currently is that, again,
our journey is just started,
so currently we are using
like a compli services,
AWS services complimentary
for RISE platform.
So one of the example, the
thing we started is like
for SAP systems to run,
we need like storage,
or compute for the system
to connect, like NetApp,
printing all of the services,
so we are trying to use those services,
we are using actually.
We are using those services
and they're helping us to,
it's a kind of a transformation
slowly getting into the cloud,
the other components spending and on-prem.
In parallel, we are also
doing the data collection,
what we call that.
So we have systems running
in different locations.
What do you call, like
on-prem or different places?
We are collecting the data
related to network storage,
how much data is getting transferred,
egress or ingress, the latency,
so we have applications.
We are evaluating those things like,
what components should be very
closer, what can be things.
So I think that way is
going to give us the clarity
to move the systems, some of
the systems into AWS proper,
what we call our own accounts.
So then run it, right?
So I think including AI as well.
So it would give us to leverage
AWS AI capabilities also.
And one more thing to tell,
we have our branding
websites for multiple brands,
they already run on AWS,
so they're helping us
with the global reach in
the strong performance,
and even for the brand advocacy.
So even that is one thing.
- Gotcha, good performance.
- Yeah, so we started with RISE,
but we do know, like
we have AWS, it's not,
it's not easy to avoid AWS, right?
(panelists laugh)
- I like that, okay.
- So AWS touches everything.
- Gotcha.
So that's where we can say
that our business is
happy with those things.
- Excellent, love hearing that.
- That's what we could share.
- So not only do you run
your enterprise workloads,
but your company's website,
your marketing platforms,
all consume AWS services, okay, excellent.
Pete, can you talk to
us about your tooling,
your automation, talk about other services
that help you complement your
SAP and SP workloads too?
I'd love to hear your perspective.
- Sure, I mean, I think a lot of
what Simon was talking
about resonates pretty well,
maybe less on the SAP
development side and more on just
how we do core cloud
infrastructure management.
Again, everything infrastructure is code,
a nice machine from GitHub.
We use a tool called Spacelift for all
of our Terraform automation
and software deployment.
And then creating those
different accounts in AWS.
A lot of what we've dipped
our toe into recently
has been with Amazon Q,
maybe because we're not
writing ABAP in that yet.
We haven't had some of the
fun things that Simon's found.
But I'm very interested
in the plug that you gave
about the workshop.
- Let's do that.
- I kinda wanna learn more about that.
But yeah, a lot of developer
efficiencies coming from that.
As someone who is, you know,
I don't get to write a lot
of Terraform these days,
a little less than I used
to, but when I'm struggling
with some sort of a complex map object,
oh, what's the most
efficient way to build this?
Something that I think I
spent literally eight hours
at re:Invent a couple
years ago working on,
I did a similar thing in about
10 minutes with Amazon Q.
So that was kind of fun.
- I love hearing that.
- A nice plug of
finding the right prompt
to ask the question.
- Definitely.
- Instead of having to
ask my colleague Zach,
who's in the audience, "Hey
Zach, how do you do this?"
So I think that's one thing
that's really important.
But other things that we're
doing with our journey to RISE,
not every one of our SAP
workloads is gonna land in RISE.
We have some specific
workloads that SAP has said,
"You know what, that probably makes sense
for you to host it yourself."
So it has been a lot of fun.
Again, a shameless plug
for our partner Lemongrass,
working with them on
really revamping the way
that we are delivering
workloads in the cloud.
They have their own, I'll
call it infrastructure
and SAP initial deployment
automated solution
that you can go from basically
a well-defined JSON document
to a working, installed vanilla SAP system
in a couple of hours, from
infrastructure provisioning,
all of your user accounts
set up at the OS level,
all of your DB users,
very, very repeatable, highly scalable.
And again, it allows our
teams on the functional side
to start working sooner.
So it's about accelerating time to value.
- That's great to hear.
- In a way that's consistent,
repeatable, and easy to execute.
And I think we find a
lot of value in that,
'cause we're able to
take a lot of the tooling
that we've already built out
for some of our non-SAP applications
and apply those same
techniques and principles.
It's a little different, but
it's more same than it is not.
So I think that's kinda cool.
And then I think last
one, it's been really fun
to watch SAP's journey as
they talk about clean core,
all of the work on the
business technology platform.
I know they do all of their
initial development in AWS,
I don't know why, I think we all know why.
So it's been fun to see not
only the new capabilities
that they are delivering,
but then also to see that oh
they have a Terraform provider.
We can find new ways to do the same things
and take those same
infrastructures code principles
and instead of, "Oh I need
a new BTP sub account,
will you do this for me manually?"
from a click ops perspective,
we take those existing
pipelines that we've written.
- That's great. Yep.
- Quick pull request.
A great example for
some of you who've been,
if anyone's familiar
with the new business
data cloud product, BDC,
one of the tools in there is Datasphere.
We did a POC earlier
this year on Datasphere,
and we were on a call with the
SAP team and they were like,
"Well, we need a new sub account,
can you vend this for us?
It'll probably take you about a week."
And I asked a few questions,
and then by the end of the meeting,
"Well, I've already vended
your account, here it is."
- I love that.
- It's ready to go.
- That's fantastic.
- So finding ways
to accelerate the easy stuff, it's a lot,
you have to go slow at the
beginning to go fast later,
but we're having a lot
of fun moving fast now.
- That's excellent. I
love hearing that journey.
Thank you so much, Pete.
ICP does build first on
AWS for a lot of reasons.
We're a first class, well
SAP's a first-class citizen
for AWS workloads as well.
We've got a robust roadmap of
innovation, joint innovation,
for those in the audience.
Anytime we launch a region,
we ensure that those systems
that support SAP
workloads, RISE and native,
are accessible and
available at launch date.
So love hearing that conversation as well.
All right, we're gonna move on
to wrapping up this customer panel.
I'm like to ask each
of our guests on stage
sort of a personal lesson in the journey,
for both transforming
your business to consume
and work with SAP in AWS,
but also in the organization.
Like from all that you've
learned and experienced,
what would you advise your
audience to take home with them?
I'll start with you, Steve.
- I mean, I guess I would
say the biggest thing for me,
I've always been in roles
where I've had to be sort
of the subject matter expert.
- Sure.
- And I think learning that,
all of us, it's a team sport.
It's an open book test, you
have help with everybody,
and it's pass-fail.
So whether you're the one
that answers the question
or whether you are bringing
as many of your friends
and colleagues and partners
to the game as possible,
like that's okay.
And kind of being able to, again,
maybe be a little bit more
humble, in terms of I don't have
to be the one that knows everything.
Not everyone knows everything,
but there are lots of people
out there who are willing,
able, incentivized to
help you on your journey.
They want to see you be successful.
So finding, I've heard
the word partnership
about 18 times up here,
finding the right partners,
whether it's with AWS,
or your different SIs
who can help you on that journey,
that's probably the most important thing.
And then I think maybe the other thing
is just don't be afraid.
We're doing a lot of things
that people have told us,
"Oh, you can't do that,
you can't make that work."
And I guess maybe the more
crass way to say that would be,
"Okay, here, hold my beer."
- I love that, I love that.
- Having fun challenging
the status quo of
just because we've
always done it that way-
- Yes.
- Doesn't mean we can't find
better ways to do things.
- Yes.
- I think having a little bit of courage,
and trusting that if you build a good team
with the right partners and
the right technical expertise,
you can do a lot of really cool things.
- I love that, so I'll just iterate
what Pete mentioned in the beginning.
It's an open book test team.
There's a pass-fail, but fail fast.
There are plenty of
opportunities and safe spaces
that we offer for you to
explore, for you to invent,
for you to simplify and learn
from that development journey.
And what did you say about failure?
Failure's not an option
or don't be afraid.
Don't be afraid. Definitely
take that first step.
There's a lot of options for
you to co-develop with AWS,
and co-develop with your
partners to find a better path.
And I love the comment,
Simon, I'm gonna come to you on this one,
that, "Oh no, you can't do that."
We hear that a lot from customers
that are exploring SAP workloads.
And I would tell you there's a lot
of opportunity to break glass.
Co-innovate with both SAP
and AWS in your journey
for your transformation.
Purna, a lesson learned for the team.
- Yeah, so specifically I would like
to highlight a few points
on the RISE journey.
So as we have been discussing,
our systems are running fine.
- Yes.
- You want to transform.
How do we prove it?
So the first thing, the thing I learned is
that let the evidence lead.
So because there are different opinions,
like, oh, this system performed better,
that one perform better,
so that benchmarking or
PO testing the things
so that cut through the opinions,
like whatever we have it, right?
So it helped us to make the decision.
So initially when we
started, it was difficult,
then it made it easy because
we have the numbers, right?
The data is key.
I think that is one of the learning.
The other thing I would
say is that always work
with your partners or vendors.
It's very critical because they
are transformation enablers.
We have been working with SAP
was one of our key partners.
So we follow them.
That is where like we started
S/4 journey at the beginning.
We are even, we are doing RISE,
we want to align with their roadmap
because they're also
one of the key enabler
because the technology
is key for the success.
So that is always ensure
that you are aligned
in different areas and
work with them closely.
Have that trust.
Giving feedback is important,
while you're appreciating
feedback is important.
That is what we do always.
So we work with them closely.
This is what, and always it's
what's in it for me, right?
So tell it like what do you,
we also tell what customer needs,
and also we can tell
the others saying that,
"Oh, this is what you
will gain with this one,"
so they can also take the
learnings, that is one thing.
The other one is take that
SAP as this is a platform.
So use that additional
transformation things to make it
as enablers for the business
growth, that is one thing.
You can use AI capabilities
or anything that you have it,
but you can start with certain point
and start enabling with
the other components.
So because I know we both were saying many
of the competence in AWS,
we are still trying to get into it.
That's why I couldn't talk much about it.
There are some interesting
technologies, right?
So the other thing is, personally,
I wanted to say the couple of things,
is always like change management is key.
- Yep.
- Yeah, so when you are
doing transformation, it touches everyone
from business within IT, right?
- Yep.
- So we are putting
a huge focus on change management,
communicating to the teams,
because sometimes they say,
"Oh, RISE is just going to cloud.
What is it? Why should I test it?
What do I need to do?"
So we are using that change management.
And also whenever something new comes up,
because it's a long journey,
so be ready to adopt those changes,
be ready, be open for it.
And capture the learnings
from every migration,
and apply to the next, that
is very important, very, very.
So we have seen issues,
some strange issues,
I mean, new issues, right,
and capture it and apply.
So because every migration is,
you'll have some new learnings as well.
And the other thing is that,
so link every iteration
with a business case,
because you start these large projects,
these things with the
business case, right?
So always you don't want
to derail the project,
so be clear on what you are
doing with the specific scope.
Anything changes, ensure that,
oh okay, I'm doing this one.
Is it within the business case?
- Yep.
- Is outside of
the business case.
- Makes sense.
- That is something.
And over prepare for cutover
and day two operations, right?
There's nothing wrong in that.
I've seen that, in my experience,
like where we've done last
four migrations, any things.
So if you were prepared, it is good,
because if nothing happens, it's fine.
But if you over prepare,
if something happens,
you're prepared for it.
So even our CA, or some of the people
when we go for meetings, they ask is that,
"Are we prepared for everything?"
It means, everything means everything.
If it goes well, if not,
it doesn't go well, right?
We don't want, they don't
want business to be impacted.
- Of course.
- They're from IT,
that is our job, so those are the things.
- Gotcha, so have evidence lead the way,
partner with everyone to help
you find the right journey,
and prepare for go live,
cutover, and day two operations.
Yeah, love, love that feedback.
Simon, I'd love for you to close,
share with us some perspectives
and lessons learned.
- Yeah, I mean, I agree with
all those lessons that I,
all of those just completely
resonated with our experience.
I definitely like the hold my beer,
'cause you hear so much about like,
this is standard architecture,
this is reference architecture,
this is certified, blah blah blah.
But I think the reality is
that like simplicity is earned.
You have to find the
solution that fits for you.
Purna was talking about
change management being really important.
I think when you're doing
something like this,
it's as much equal,
it's equal parts about
transforming the culture
as it's doing,
as it is like transformation-
- Definitely.
- For mission critical systems.
But I guess my personal lesson,
just laying some context,
CBA's quite a big place.
I think a lot of us work at
very large organizations.
Ours is about 50,000 people,
huge distributed organization,
different priorities,
different silos that people work in.
It's kind of a tough thing
to navigate at times.
And you sort of fall into the
trap of being in what I call,
what Dr. Seuss called
actually, the waiting place,
which is you're waiting
for someone to respond,
or you're waiting for somebody
to do the work that they promised to do.
or you're waiting for
the right conditions.
And at CBA, we've got
like three core values,
care, commitment, and courage.
And if you look at our recognition portal,
I'm sure a lot of companies
have these sorts of things,
you see loads and loads of recognitions
around care and commitment.
Those are the easy things to identify.
But it's sort of more difficult
to identify what courage means.
And for me, I think like
courage is taking action,
just moving forward.
And we did this, we did an offsite
at the AWS office pretty early on,
like 100, 120 people in the room.
And I think this is sort of pivotal
to the transformation of our culture,
'cause we sort of sat everyone there
and talked about what this
means, like laid out the vision,
and not just what it
means to the organization,
but what it means
to all of the people
involved for their careers.
A lot of them have worked in this space
for quite a long time.
But we did this exercise
where we picked some
of the Amazon leadership principles
that I thought were
particularly relevant for this.
And the one that I really
liked was bias for action.
And everyone sort of said
what they think a bias
for action looks like.
And to me, that's courage.
And it sort of reminds me of,
we talked about Kevin Smith,
there's this quote from Kevin
Smith that I really like.
Do you know Kevin Smith?
Who's 40 in this audience?
He is the director of like, "Clerks,"
"Chasing Amy," "Mallrats," et cetera.
And he was talking about how
he succeeded in Hollywood
sort of against the odds,
'cause they're really low
budget productions initially.
And he said that the secret was
to have a reasonable
amount of unreasonableness.
And I really like that because I think
that's true of any hard thing,
and certainly it's true
of like transformations
at this kind of scale.
And if I reflect on our journey,
we basically ran ambo the entire time.
Everyone said, "There's no
way you're gonna hit the date,
you're gonna run behind.
There's so much schedule compression.
There's a lot of external
dependencies," et cetera.
So we ran ambo,
and it kind of led to a
bit of a mantra of mine.
Amber is a racing color.
I was watching a lot of Formula
One during this program.
And for those of you who are
familiar with Formula One,
McLaren won the
Constructors Championships.
They're orange, or
papaya, or amber, really.
But it became sort of a bit
of a signal or a shorthand.
Amber is like focused, and determined,
and consistent under pressure.
And that's how we behaved as a team.
If this had gone, if we'd gone gone red,
then I'd be telling a story about Ferrari,
but I think Amber is probably
the best place to be.
So I think yeah, that's it for me.
I think it's culture, culture
is like pivotal to this.
It's about being a
little bit unreasonable.
It's about having courage
and always moving forward.
- That's excellent. It's
not just about technology.
I mean this really is a people
business. Keep me honest.
I heard you say care,
commitment, and courage.
- That's it.
- Principles that the company
has found it that you guys
live by and work with.
And the fact that the project
was amber with urgency
has helped you reach that finish line,
and really create a
transformational experience
for all banking customers in Australia.
- It's also, like it lifted the standard
of our whole bank, right,
'cause it redefined what's possible
and that bar for how you deliver
and what excellence looks like.
- Yeah, so I would say,
for the audience members,
this is not a short journey.
It's a transformational journey
that you're gonna partner
with both your cloud provider,
SAP, and your systems integrators
to get you to your final state.
And that final state is also evolving,
with each of the panelists discussing
how they're modernizing,
how they're automating,
and leveraging AWS
services to help innovate
and create a new experience
for their customers too.
I'm honored to be here to
hear everyone's journey.
Thank you to each of you
to share your perspectives,
and to our audience for listening in.
Thank you to all of you.
We'll wrap it up, and if
you have any questions,
come on by tomorrow to Smith and Wollensky
and we'll talk to you soon.
Thank you, again.
(audience applauds)